hey youtubers is charlie so really
awesome thing just happened James Gunn
screen part of guardians of the galaxy
two for vin diesel so they were both
fangirling on the footage let's just how
awesome it was and then they broke it
down a little bit so I'm gonna play this
video then I should include all the good
stuff and then at the end I'll just do
bullet points just because there's so
much stuff that they talk about but you
can go back and forth in the video
because its pretty long so here we go
can't believe you have to wait so long
can see this movie is it long it's May
5th May 5th that's not that long well
it's a little long we'll get there we
feel good about it though right I mean
it's it's it really is good about us
something that is is we from the
beginning I mean I think the sequel has
been it's it's been something that's you
know it's a miraculous feeling to be a
part of all of this because the first
movie was quite inspired and then to
have the second movie I don't want to
say be even more so but to be even more
so in certain ways in a great experience
working on this and to see every single
person that was on the first movie come
back and who all did a good job on the
first movie and up their game up to
their good you could see an animal I
mean Rooker Rooker's in this movie is
like so fun he like when you watch his
character it's like watching 20 movies
compiled into one all the moments that
you love about 20 movies whenever you
see him on screen yeah he a good thing
about rookeries he's he's one of those
actors that's so committed he's not
worried about anything else but what
goes on that yeah he's a true
true actor and and you see it in his
work yeah but but Bautista Bautista is a
guy who came from the wrestling world
and did Chronicles of Riddick yeah and
then and did played one kind of
character and then nobody knew what was
coming when he put on the skins of
tracks when he delved into that game
comedic genius really in this movie he
comido genius so funny
cell phone in a refreshing way and we
don't have we don't see that kind of
comedic genius every day yeah it's it's
refreshing it's coming from it starts by
coming from a place of confidence he's
such a good guy he's such a caring guy
such a good guy he's a humble guy i mean
i think there's understand humility like
he just is wrong and that's why i like
batista so much as an actor is he's
really present like an old-time like a
Steve McQueen right who you know wasn't
always turning in these bravura
performances but when he was on screen
he was just there just their teeth
that's that's day beauty supplies tracks
and you love to Jackson the first one
which see him he's really oh I think
Chris Pratt was born to play Peter quill
he's perfect plain and simple I don't I
don't know i mean i don't know how it
all happened to have the universe
obviously you made that call me early on
but I saw it in the first movie I'm
seeing it now Chris Pratt was born to
play Peter Quillin you don't have that
in Hollywood all that it's a rare thing
in how they would when we together we
screen tested probably 30 actors as we
were trying to find Peter quill and I
didn't even want to see Chris at first
there's a lot of people know this story
because I thought you know he was
overweight at the time he was like a
comedy guy and I didn't think he was the
right person for the role but he came in
and he was doing his audition and 20
seconds into his audition I month that's
the guy I knew it in my heart after
searching for like four months trying to
find the right guy in auditioning a list
actors nobody actors and everybody in
between and finally it's like that
magical moment it's like when you find
the woman you fall in love with in your
life that's the one she's you know and
that's what that's what he was it was
like finding Chris's is Peter Quillin oh
my god and he and he just you know it's
in his DNA you know that his instincts
the founding fathers of the character
yeah it's just you know that something
so refreshing about watching him play
this character because it was a
character that he was actually born to
play and listen there's Zoe Saldana it's
like in this movie like I really feel
like we give the female characters a
chance to shine let zoe saldana comes in
and she is so wonderfully beautiful as
her character it's it's touching and
then Karen Gillan is Neville as nebula
comes in who's her sister and she's a
completely you know much deeper
character than we got in the first movie
so we get to know her the character the
the that that sisterhood that you
explore in this movie is something that
we haven't seen it in film yeah
definitely haven't seen it this level
and that's what one of the things the
movie is about is you know I say the
first movie really was about becoming a
family this movie is about being a
family right what's harder becoming a
family or being a being that there's a
clearly family that we were you really
have to deal with each other and that's
what this movie is about and their
sisters they are family whether they
like it or not and they have to they
also want to kill each other so it adds
a new twist to the sister to being a
sister and then Tom Clemente F who plays
mantis who's the new character is all
crazy crazy crazy crazy good and you
know in the same way like Peter quill
you know as Chris came in and put in was
Peter or Dave came in and audition racks
on like who else could play Drax but
they but it was the only one that's
right that's what Palm was like his
mantis she's like she's emotional that's
she's um you know intense and she's
funny and she is like a true alien
creature in real life Wow and yeah and
that's that's what she betrays all your
female characters are so strong it like
you just talked about Sally my daughter
who you know sunyani it just looks up to
the strength and confidence is Ellie
and she's gonna and we're all gonna go
see a movie together this weekend but um
she has that in this film it's okay she
she looks like she's stronger than
everybody in the world yeah she carries
herself about kind of confidence and
that's beautiful Kurt Russell Caruso is
such Kurt Russell's one of my gems in
the fast franchise right yeah he's
somebody that is just an asset all the
way around because yeah I remember
talking you early on when we're thinking
about hiring did you you like the guy
welcome because VIN knows I like to work
with people who I like it's like I was
short to be talking with people that you
don't like totally right and I I and I'm
like it'll just hurt a guy you like is
he a cool guy you know a cool ghazi
bitter from being around for solo but
he's 19 hours on set every day and yes
cited about cited role he loves being
that character and he's amazing in that
way and that's infectious when you see
someone that enthusiastic about the
character that they're playing it's
infectious yeah it makes everyone around
you everyone around stand pick up their
game uh and he's just I've been and I
haven't been doing it for as long and we
don't make are all in hello who goes it
uh guys uh you are in the room you are
in the guardians of the galaxy room with
none other than the incredible James
Gunn I'm blown away with what I saw you
just hold on May 5th is coming you're
gonna see vol two guardians of the
galaxy so we gotta say I'm so happy that
people like James Gunn Vin Diesel who
are very successful and don't need to be
as open as they are are so connected
with the audience like to just totally
normal dudes who just happen to be major
major personalities in Hollywood but
they show you just how normal they are
when they start fangirling on all the
other actors in the movie Kurt Russell
to like if you just rewind to like the
last two minutes of their video there
it's like they just got progressively
and progressively drunker is
they're watching all their friends on
screen just saying how much they love
them how amazing they are so things like
this are just like the best thing ever I
mean obviously it's not actual footage
but just a bullet point the really
important Guardians two things from the
movie that they talked about one they
said it's a movie about being a family
so like the team comes together in the
first guardians film the team is already
together I mean it gets a little bigger
and guardians to but you get to see
those family relationships play out
particularly with the female characters
like Gomorrah and nebula so if you felt
like those characters were underserved
in the first film they're basically
saying they double down on that in the
second film because they're amazing
actors but you always want to double
down on the really interesting
characters that you might not have spent
a whole lot of time with in the first
film so Peter quill search for his
father ego the Living Planet played by
Kurt Russell is still very important to
the film but really the story of the
film is about the family relationship of
the guardians and you have like all
these smaller family units within that
like you had the family unit of Peter
quill and his father you have the family
unit of the Guardians itself you have
Thanos's family unit which is Gamora
nebula then you have new characters like
mantis coming into the family so I'm
actually really curious about mantis we
haven't seen any footage with her yet
because it sounds like there's some CG
with her character but she'll probably
be in that first trailer and I know
everyone's asking when they're going to
drop it I'm expecting the first footage
to actually drop around Star Wars rogue
one is like the other big Disney space
franchise it's relatively soon after dr.
strange comes out so there's a lot of
Marvel Disney things happening during
that time of year so awareness is really
high so they'll probably drop it then
but they'll probably be a really big
version of the trailer during the Super
Bowl but like they said the movies
coming out May 5th the Super Bowl is
usually in February so they'll
definitely be a trailer before the Super
Bowl usually it's about six months out
when they drop the first footage so for
those that are wondering you're probably
gonna get some new guardians footage for
Christmas or if you don't celebrate
Christmas for the holidays or whatever
either way new footage it's going to be
awesome but in the spirit of gift-giving
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner mouth-breather you went a
30-dollar amazon gift card is basically
for the value of the civil war blu-ray
which is coming out really soon I think
it's on digital right now so you can use
it for whatever you want just be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so i can get your contact
details and there is
new round that starts now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video I'll keep
doing the blu-ray give away till it
drops which is a little bit later this
month but whole bunch more Marvel DC
stuff happening in the next week or so
so get hype well you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for that
funny thor ragnarok trailer and you can
click here for the captain america civil
war bloopers again thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight